[Music]
hi there it is
stainer you yelled at me and anybody who
hasn't seen she's out of my league it's
wondering what's happening in both of
our lives I'm wearing my Skechers
shape-ups and I'm okay with that so you
should be also that's all so recently I
threw up in the street in Washington DC
which is in a big deal I do that a lot I
like to drink what was different about
this time there was something different
cuz I threw up on myself this weekend
but this time as I was walking and right
when I begin to vomit you know you're
just starting alright as I began I just
turned and I turned I made eye contact
with a woman sitting outside of his
Starbucks and then I held eye contact as
I vomited so that's terrible you know
for her especially because I know the
context I know what's going on but she
doesn't you know all she does is she's
sipping a frappe a latte or whatever
they drink there and she turn and all
she sees as a man go I also walk like a
zombie when I vomit what's going on in
her reality you know does she go home
and she talks to her friends about her
day and she's like oh my god I was so
ugly this morning I made a man vomit
feel bad about that
let's do a quick character for you guys
this is a construction worker who's very
masculine but he has moments where he's
very effeminate oh yo Tony what'd he do
man told you guys smooth the cement I
was gonna do the whole thing over so I
like to make it face when I get my
driver's license photo taken you're not
allowed to in California actually I know
this cuz I called and I asked and they
said if you make a face and they have to
retake the photograph if they do it
three times you don't get your license
for the day so I was really bummed but
then I came up with what I think is one
of the smartest ideas I've ever had in
my life
what are they gonna do if you walk into
the DMV already making the face
pretty sorry huh so now you want to pick
a face that doesn't look like you're
trying to make a face but you still want
to look weird so that when I went with
was this
[Laughter]
and that's what I held for an hour and
25 minutes I went through every single
line you know I was like I wasn't even
sitting I was just crouching yeah so
then it came time to go the photography
line and I go up and I give him my
paperwork you know
I don't also don't know why I changed my
voice like I didn't need to you know
like it just felt it matched so I handed
him all my paperwork he wasn't even
looking he was on the computer and he
looked up I swear to God he goes like
this now I realize I'm the one creating
the mischief here but if you're
reflexive reaction to a strange looking
individual is perhaps don't work in the
photography section of the DMV so you
say good time stand behind the white
line so I turn and as they turn to be in
a laughs and I had to compose myself
because I realized that the only thing
that he could say when it comes time to
take the photograph is smile this guy
when he smiles can look real weird so I
got ready to take the photograph I stood
behind the white line
[Laughter]
it's like okay smile
that's it sound like y'all buy a
driver's license thank you very much my
name is TJ Miller this is my first time
on late-night television
[Applause]
you